When which feminism began
was by calling it to question received notions of what a woman is,
right? They tell you you belong in the household.
They tell you you're good for reproduction.
They tell you you're not able to do that kind of work.
You can't engage in sports.
You can't be a public speaker.
You certainly can't be a politician.
You can't be an intellectual.
Or if you are, you're never gonna be quite as good.
So what has feminism been about?
It's been about contesting received ideas of what a woman is.
Why did we start women studies,
feminist studies, gender studies?
Well, we did
because we wanted to call into question
these presuppositions that had been taken for granted for too long.
So we ask the question, what is it to be a woman
or what does it mean to be a woman?
Smoked above wire, one is not born but rather becomes a woman.
Really? It's not biologically,
it's not the biological function that makes you a woman?
No, it's not the biological function.
It's actually nothing specific about the biology
that alone defines you as a woman.
It's part of the picture. But how you live that,
why you do with that is a question of history.
It's a question of freedom.
It's how you negotiate your situation,
which is an historically complicated one
where there established norms and roles.
So feminism has always kept the question open,
what is a woman? And refused To answer it,
refuse to answer it on principle
because we don't know all the things women can be and do.
And we're not about to say in advance,
this is who you are, stay within your limits,
stay within this category.
We've decided this is what a woman is and you have to live there.
No, we don't.
We don't do that. We're, we're freedom struggle.